Michael Fabiano NFL Network senior
fantasy analyst
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
good to see you fabs always a pleasure
um if you don't mind me saying it's much
more pleasurable for me not just to see
you but seeing in between us the Vinnie
Paul trophy that's the reason I'm here
you can bring either gold the trophy
named after the late drummer and
co-founder of Pantera who has won this
trophy before in the past of the Allison
chains this is a lot of birdie Fantasy
Football League that Chris Brockman and
I bought one last year thank you for
bringing maestro congratulations well
done well done thank you yeah and on the
side just reading off the previous
winners of this of this award good names
right well you that's a no one last year
yeah we we had a shot to play you in the
finals but we got taken out by Cantrell
who you took out yes
Cantrell beat us in 2016 our first year
so close and had we had we beaten him
instead of me being dressed up like a
Steel Panther he would have had to sing
let it go acoustic I do tell you though
you are rockin the steel Panthers gear
was pretty awesome that was that was
good it's very it's something that it's
tough for me to live down it's something
Scott ian has won at twice you only want
to be on this list twice the 2015
champion we were not part of the league
until 2016 down and he won it in 2012
Dane Cook won in 2014 Vinnie Paul in
2013 rest in peace and then meatloaf
took it down in 2010 course was that one
of his 42 championships I hear me loaf
plays in like 30 or 40 leagues like he's
every year it's ridiculous I played
against him like 15 years ago in a
league yeah meatloaf by the way the word
it's great to have a trophy
where's meatloaf on it and in the
initial an arguable inner Matt Willig
who as you know is a former offensive
lineman in the league who many people
know famously because he's one of the
many Marauders in the Capital One what's
in hawala commercial right yep and also
famous one of the my favorite Steve
Mariucci stories
running back Kevin burrito always was on
his cell phone because he was homesick
his teammates had had enough of it so
Matt Willie confiscated the phone in a
manner that Kevin Barlow was so upset he
was went crying to mariachi's office
Mariucci retrieved the phone from the
behind of Matt willing that'll make you
not want your phone confirmed when he
was on the show seconds after retrieving
the phone for Kevin Barlow Barlow is
back on the inaugural winner of this
league Matt willing already a champion
before he won by a true story first
overall pick in this year's draft say
Quan yeah I'm stutter
now take one I mean every statistical
category at the running back position he
was near the top or at the top touches
he is going to be a monster a guy who
can catch 90 balls in his sleep and he's
the offense in New York there so you're
not concerned that he is the offense in
New York and that there's gonna be so
many keys and eight potentially nine man
boxes that Eli is gonna have to break -
Odell nothing he did not face he's fine
okay and then number two you have on
your list is Christian McCaffrey love
Camaro yes Camaros at 3 now now Zeke
would be - except for we're dealing with
this holdout situation so let me ask you
this question he signs before week 1
even if it's the night before and you
have you have a draft you take him - yep
you do right now I'm taking him for if I
can get him even if he's holding out yep
you're taking him I don't see him
missing regular-season games and if he
does I don't see him missing many so I'm
not as concerned his situation is
different than say Le'Veon Bell or
Melvin Gordon so I have a lot of
confidence that he will play the
majority of the games this where do you
have Le'Veon Bell v at
you do about what about overall I mean
at what point do you if the overall I'm
a running backs guy ok yeah I don't have
my first wide receiver coming off the
board until a couple pics after ladies
and who's that a nuke yeah DeAndre
Hopkins and then Davante Adams is
closely after him first rounders
why is Davante Adams up there I know
he's an elite receiver I get it
but aren't you concerned with the way
that the Packers offense might look now
with Lafleur and Aaron Rodgers no
concern score fewer than 16 PPR points
in a single game last year he was so
consistent and then they've got this
dude Aaron Rodgers thrown on the
football who's you know been pretty good
during his career in the NFL right so
Adams to me is a lock first round pick I
have no concerns about him whatsoever
he's gonna get targeted at a ton in that
off okay so you're his top receivers
walk me down that board Mike yeah so
you've got knew you've got Adams of
course Julio Jones is gonna be in the
mix Michael Thomas Oh BJ
Tyreke he'll also there know Antonio
Brown in my top five know Antonio Brown
in my top seven right now he's eighth
and he's one of those guys that when I'm
up and say the third round and if he's
still there I'm thinking I really don't
want to take him right but I have to the
regression is coming for him
he blocked me on Twitter by the way yeah
15 touchdowns is not gonna happen he
goes from an offense that had the most
pass attempts to one that had the 16th
most last year fifth most offensive
plays for the Steelers Raiders were at
24 Ben Roethlisberger years together
great rapport Derek Carr how much work
if they gotten in so far I know right
that's gotta be so I mean like a beacon
block me all he want he can complain
about his helmet and his feet are messed
up regressions coming where are you on
girly where do you stand on Todd Gurley
here
so I've done a lot of mocks I've done
some real drafts too I've actually
gotten him a lot at the end of the
second round because at that point I'm
willing to take the discount and I'm
willing to take the risk because even if
Todd Gurley doesn't see as many touches
which it seems like he won't he'll Steve
he'll still see enough opportunities to
be a high-end RB 2 and Sean McVeigh is
going to give him all the opportunities
near the goal line to so I'm
to take the risk there I've got a league
where I have Zeke Gurley and Antonio
Brown and my first three pigs
well I'm sweating that one a little bit
we our Los Angeles broadcasting senators
put up on the board Michael Fabiano's
top five fantasy busts todd gurley leads
the list yeah
with tight end Eric Ebron who was mr.
touchdown he was like Chris Carter right
last year
Jordan Howard the running back of the
Eagles then quarterbacks Big Ben and Tom
Brady why are these wild when Grilli was
going in the first round
wait earlier in the offseason I've
changed it since then okay at this
second round discount I'm gonna take him
Roethlisberger no a be before a B was in
Pittsburgh Big Ben's average finish at
quarterback 14th so not a QB one Tom
Brady
he's got the loss of Rob Gronkowski's
big in his career average three fewer
fantasy points in games
Gronkowski did not play right Sonne
Michele is another guy who wasn't on
this list I'm a little bit concerned
about with the knee with Damien Harris
coming in he bronzed easy like 14
touchdowns last things and he's never
doing that again
and in games where he played with Jack
Doyle his targets went split in half so
he's a guy that I would be avoiding as a
top eight pick at tight end how come
Michael far beyond our here on the
Richard show and how come
juju Smith Shuster is viewed as a
dynamite to with a Antonio Brown as the
one but as the one assuming that
whoever's number two is not as good as
juju that juju can't overcome that in
the same way that say Kwan's gonna
overcome a ton of defenses I have juju
in the second round you know he's one of
my top eight wide receivers a head of a
Antonio Brown so I'm all in on Judy [ __ ]
masseuse toe so then why is Antonia wise
why is big been a bust
I mean that this is a place that keeps
churning out the receivers eggs born
after another lose a player like that in
an offense like Judy is great in all
right but you had a be and juju Smith
Shuster huge target shares both of them
over 24 percent last season you lose
that you bring in Donte Moncrief
I like James Washington a lot as a
sleeper but neither one of those guys is
going to make up for the production
Antonio Brown took to Oakland michael
Fabiano NFL Network senior fantasy
analyst who right here in the Rich Eisen
show and Michael if you don't mind you
have to speak up because it's difficult
to hear you over this trophy that we
just I'm sorry did you just say
something it's it's just blocked by this
trophy that we we won and plucked from
you in between the two of us here and
hopefully I'll be getting that back this
is just so great
Brockman by the way the chief grocery
shop were the last two drafts of this
fantasy league last three dress well we
are I'm coming this year I've not been
at the can't romance yet I have not seen
wait do you see the artwork the oil
paintings of half-naked individual for
SiriusXM because serious to the radio it
up they cover up paintings on the radio
yes
that's weird they have Sirius XM
understand the idea of signage Japan
where tenth your ninth so I would share
how did that happen I would show got to
yeah it's a an MS got one it's okay look
it's okay
there if they're concerned about our
last two champions that seasons together
it is it's alright we're coming from
anyway I would give you some ideas of my
draft strategy but you're right in front
of me I'll tell you what I'm doing what
are you doing I'm hopefully hopefully
gonna end up with a combination of James
Connor Nick Chubb or Joe Mixon with
those picks so you've been for nine to
nine your nine twelve we're ten eleven
I'm looking to go running back running
back but you know what if I can't do
that I'll always fall back on a Julio
Jones you getting all this Brockman you
get all this to tell you right now I
think we'd go running back wide receiver
you get one of each certainly we're in a
PPR League
what part of the reason why this trophy
is on this desk is because that man over
there took Mike Mike Thomas who can't
guard and feelin and we would get its
what it was a water
point per catch domination point for
catch I mean those two guys together
last year a dad a hell of a catch radius
last year for us for for the touch of
the Vermeil but I think we'd probably go
running back wide receiver with that
right gotta grab a running back there
and at number 10 what is your philosophy
on quarterbacks when we're not read one
wait and then I wait more and I wait
more I'll never get my homes unless
Rogers fall select the sixth or
seventh-round I'm not getting him super
early last year yeah before it was super
early though you did who are you and
this is a direct quote this is the pick
that's going to win the championship
this yes and I thought it was let me
tell you Chris did you remember the
trades I made last year
every time I trade you for a guy he got
hurt obj got him hurt AJ Green got him
hurt you know why that happen at law I
can tell you why I have bad luck I'll
tell you why haven't you or the workers
in the trade the fantasy gods are
punishing you for the amount of times
you think everybody's dumb as a rock or
you actually give the real offer the
ball the lowball from Michael Fabiano is
so low the ball is at the center of the
earth that the core of this planet
Magnum is the low ball that you and so
it's the gods are punishing you the
number of times you're just like okay I
was born today you were born yesterday
here's my offer and it's just like dude
and I will call you up Brockman and I'm
gonna have me a trade
Fabiano and we have a did and it was
like it took three four goes at it
because we're like we're not gonna do
that
we're not gonna do that you do that all
the time which is why when you finally
do get some room to say yes you have
been punished to me like I would rather
be in a league
question is
would you rather Brockman being a league
with somebody who does that or taps out
like The Bella Twins did last year
because they were so bad that they
stopped yeah stop setting their eyes
rather at least get the lowball trades
cuz you know they're paying attention no
but I'd rather also get the win it was
an easy win when you're going against
somebody who puts seven people in the
roster it's an easy win friend there's
there's no coincidence that they are not
back did you did you inform the Bella
Twins that they're out I did it was cool
because they're still in the NFL
celebrity League so they're happy
they're all good okay but that doesn't
mean they can't come back at some point
the picture they do they hit you with
the folding chair or something did the
folding chair yeah who is in the league
this year do we know who's in the
fantasy so the two of us CJC
jerrican yes Jeff Garlin Garland Miz
who's always a lot of fun yes Michael
Buble is in the league yeah I think he's
coming to the draft ooh look at you man
[Music]
I'm trying to think off the top of my
head there one of the guys from the Red
Hot Chili Peppers is in it also okay I'm
Scottie in yep is it me no more they're
gonna do 12 teams at 12 2010 it's 10 I'm
missing somebody
can you please text garland to remember
to bring his computer this year if
you're gonna show up originally last
without anything and had to do the whole
draft on his phone the entire draft he
was flirting with Nicole and Brianna and
guess what all he did that's The Bella
Twins I guess I guess and guess who
guess who faced us in the finals
Garlan and guess who we won this trophy
case we can't say Garland's team name
every single week Louis grandma's and
then it's a very derogatory word for the
male anatomy if it's very very
fascinating that yeah exactly you know
what I'm glad to hear this information
because I'm gonna if I if I may look
directly at the camera thank you I'm
gonna say something that I've never said
into a microphone
Buble is going down
come you wanna you want to see we're
gonna croon your ass right out of this
league that good rosette was that too
aggressive sweet man family man man
family man yeah great voice a one
crooner maybe turn it down a little okay
sorry I'm sorry I got the Vinnie Paul
trophy right here so now having lost to
us does that make you a junior fantasy
both work for the NFL Network I won this
trophy you didn't even make the playoffs
yeah does that make me a senior fantasy
I know I'm not on fantasy live like you
and I know
does that make you now a junior fantasy
you can take the title my friend in fact
the first week week one of game day
morning yes
I'll interview you and you can do the
start - no that's okay about that that's
all right I don't know if the UH the
producers would go for something
Andy Greg wouldn't doubt it Michael
underscore Fabiano on both Twitter and
Instagram yes sir thank you sir
appreciate that how can we raise money
now what's the good show
the Allison Chainz auction starting up
on August 26th just ten days ebay.com
slash Allison chains or you can go to
Alice in Chains calm check it out all
kinds of awesome memorabilia a couple of
signed WWE championship belts a private
guitar lesson with Jerry Cantrell
there's all kinds of great stuff right
and it all goes to a great cause you
know what great cause it is Saint you
that's right that's always it goes to
the charity of choice of the winner of
the trophy and of course we chose st.
Jude Children's Research Hospital people
go and give that money again you go to
ebay.com slash Alice in Chains or Alice
in Chains com will be able to see what
items are up for auction amazing and
start bidding August 26 and start
bidding and she's all the money goes to
a great spot st. Jude Children's
Research Hospital chosen by me the
champion along with my buddy Chris
Brockman yeah good to see you Michael I
just can't see you behind this arm to
say good body
by looking at the trophy this is my
friend I just saw a hand above the
trophy that's what your time we're back
with more ammo for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app